we're going to start today with
something that i know some in my
audience don't really want to accept
but when we deny
an empirical reality
we're really all the worse off there's
no advantage to denying an empirical
reality and the empirical reality is
that joe biden's approval rating
is not good and it's actually getting
down to
where donald trump was at this point in
his presidency and we're going to talk
about why we'll talk about the
implications and we'll talk about what
could be done to reverse it but
it is now very clear
that uh joe biden has a political
problem on his hands and as a result
democrats have a political problem on
their hands in terms of the numbers joe
biden's approval
has dropped below 40 percent for the
first time in his presidency according
to the real clear politics average of
polls now what real clear politics does
is it takes
a a number of different polls
individually some of which might have a
bias like for example it includes the
rasmussen poll
which can have uh sort of a a right-wing
bias it includes the ibd tip poll which
some say has a bit of a left-wing bias
etc and you get an average and yesterday
that average dropped for the first time
below 40. to 39.8 and today has
recovered just a sliver to exactly 40.
and as you can see if you're watching
that's the lowest that it has been uh
since the start of joe biden's
presidency and if we ask the question
well
it's common that sometimes presidents
come into office with a higher approval
and then it sort of declines over time
how does it compare to past presidents
and 538 does that for us and what you
see
when you look
uh is that um joe biden came into office
with a significantly higher approval
than donald trump about 10 points higher
and that has slowly gone down down down
to where they are now almost identical
at this point in their presidencies
biden and trump are now basically equal
in terms of approval joe biden's
approval is well below where barack
obama's was at this point in his
presidency
it because of 9 11 is dramatically below
where george w bush's was although
george w bush did ultimately squander
the high approval that came in the
aftermath of 9 11.
joe biden's approval although for a
period of time was higher than bill
clinton's at this point in his
presidency it has now dropped below
uh biden's approval is well below where
george h.w bush's was
it is below where ronald reagan's was
and if we want to go back further it is
also below where jimmy carter's was
uh similar to gerald ford
well below richard nixon and you know we
could go back further and and it's a
different era if you go back to lbj
kennedy and eisenhower uh it's a
completely different uh
political era altogether i don't know
how much we get
from looking at those numbers but the
point here is joe biden does have a
political problem on his hands now
why is joe biden's approval so low it's
a combination of things first and
foremost uh it has been some time since
joe biden has had
what we might consider a major
accomplishment
um
relatively early on joe biden had the
covet stimulus package
uh shortly after that there was the
dramatic rollout of uh the accelerated
rollout of covet vaccines but then
joe biden got hit with the delta variant
then joe biden left afghanistan which i
believe is 110 the right decision but
the right was able to weaponize it
pretty successfully in terms of saying
it was chaotic and misplanned and it
said all the things that it would have
been under trump as well but that hurt
joe biden infrastructure was done but it
got relatively little coverage and then
now
there's sort of this lull and so i think
there's a couple different questions
that we could ask one in a vacuum
what could joe biden do to raise his
approval in the short term i did a tick
tock clip about this by by popular
demand and there's a few different
things that joe biden could do in the
short term although i don't know how
much they would benefit him long term
you know we've talked about the student
loan forgiveness
there is no doubt that doing some
student loan forgiveness would help joe
biden's approval rating in the immediate
but would it really help him and would
it help democrats longer term maybe
maybe not i'm not sure
something on decriminalizing marijuana
federally i think would be very popular
but could he get it done
um is a a sort of a real question
what about announcing that the pandemic
is over and uh this question which just
three days ago was sort of like yeah
maybe
it is very clear that due to political
pressure and quite frankly fatigue with
the pandemic
numerous states are now saying we're
getting rid of masks we're getting rid
of masks in schools we're getting rid of
in some cases requirements for
vaccination to go to certain types of
businesses and my expectation is that
for political reasons
uh between now and march 1st which is
the date of the next state of the union
that joe biden is going to give i expect
it could be next week it could be on the
day of the state of the union sometime
between now and march 1st i expect the
biden white house
to come out and say
we are now at the point where life can
really start going back to normal now
there's divergent views as i talked to
you about yesterday as to whether that
is a scientifically and medically sound
thing to do some say there's really no
more milestones to wait for if we don't
get a more deadly variant it's sort of
going to be like this for the next
however many years there's really
nothing else to wait for it's time to go
back to quote normal and let people make
decisions for themselves about their
level of risk the counterpoint to that
is nat there's still a lot of people
dying as a result of the surge that
started a couple months ago it is not
the time to do it i think that there is
significant
uh
leaning right now within the biden white
house to sometime between now and march
1st take a sort of mission accomplished
uh approach make a mission accomplished
type statement
when it comes to covid whether it will
end up being the right thing or not i
don't know
but joe biden does have a political
problem on his hands and these are some
of the things certainly that uh
when it comes to kovid are uh are being
considered and very quickly because
we're basically eight and a half months
from the midterms
what happens in the next six weeks is
going to set the tone
for what the midterm races are going to
look like in terms of what republicans
will use to run against democrats the
culture stuff for sure
but what else are they going to use and
there's this limited window now to set
the tone for that for what that's going
to be and of course we'll be following
what it is
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our long
time sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman